welcome back our next topic is bayesian
additive regression trees
um also known could you how do you say
that trevor
bot
i just want to make fun of your accent
it's bart
that's what i said
bot okay so we're going to discuss
bayesian additive regression trees or
bart an ensemble method that uses
decision trees
as it's building blocks
now we've talked about two or three
other methods already for using decision
trees in
supervised learning bagging in random
forests for example make predictions
from an average of regression trees
each one is built up using a random
sample of data we either sample the data
as a bootstrap sample and or we sample
the features right
and each one's built up separately and
they're they're averaged at the end
boosting the other hand uses a weighted
sum of trees
each of which is constructed from
fitting a tree to the residual of the
current fit so that they're not built
independently but they're built in
sequence right so each tree
tries to capture the signal that's not
yet accounted for by the current set of
trees
so it's kind of a forward stepwise ford
stage-wise method so rob what do what
does bart do differently
well if you wait for the next slide
you'll find out okay bart is related
both to random force and boosting
it construct it has the random feature
as in bagging and boot and random force
that it draws random samples to build
trees
but it also has a similar to boosting in
that it uses the other trees and kind of
a parser residual
to choose the next tree to improve the
overall fit
to try to account for the
the signal that's not been captured by
the current model so it's got
similarities to both random force
bagging and boosting
the main novelties you'll see is the way
the way in which the new trees are
generated which is quite different than
the other methods
it can be it can be applied to
regression classification other other
problems like survival analysis but here
we'll just focus on regression
okay so here first of all in a picture
this is the idea and then we'll go into
details on the in the coming slides a
number of trees are fit in parallel so
one chooses a number k maybe a few
hundred
and
b steps in each stage and each tree is
is is changed b times as the as the
algorithm proceeds
for each tree say the first tree we
start with the root node right so they
all start with the root node and then
perturbations are applied to the trees
to to change them these perturbations as
we'll see can be of various kinds we can
add add a branch
we can delete a branch or or we can
change the predicted values at each of
the nodes in this case
since we start with the root node each
of these trees gets a single split added
to them although the split points and
split variables are different
and then at the next stage this tree
we've added another branch
which is on the left this tree we've
actually removed the single the existing
branch is back to the root node and this
tree again we add another branch on the
left side and this continues for
maybe a few thousand steps
these perturbations to get a whole
sequence of trees of varying sizes with
with different predictions in the root
notes so robert so it looks like so the
iterations where you go one through b
and seems like what you're doing is
maintaining k trees at each step exactly
and each step you change each of those k
trees in some kind of random way
exactly yeah so at the end we make our
final prediction by averaging the
prediction over all k
sequences of trees and all steps b
okay
so let's actually go over that now more
detail with some notation so the number
of
number of regression trees
that that was the different columns in
that previous picture is k
and that the number of iterations for
which we apply the algorithm are called
b
okay
and uh the prediction at at a query
point x for the k 3 and the b iteration
we'll call it
f hat
suit b sub k
so at the end of the of each iteration
we have k trees and the
our prediction for at the beat step is
simply the
the sum of those predictions
okay
so what those iterations look like at
the beginning
uh we as you saw in the picture the each
tree starts with a single root node and
the prediction in each tree is just the
average of the observations
of all observations so our overall
prediction
at the first step is simply
this average so we divide each of them
by those averages by k so that when we
sum up k of them we we get the overall
mean of y exactly
and then in coming iterations 2 3 etc
this is what happens we take the parser
residual
for all tree but the kth tree
we subtract off the current fit
and we form what's called the parser
residual
and then we build our tree on the parser
residual
but we might think well i'll just build
a regression tree directly but from
scratch but instead what bart does is it
takes the existing tree at that step and
it perturbs it in a certain way
okay and
so
right instead of instead of fitting a
fresh tree it choose a perturbation
of the existing tree from the the
previous step at in the for the cave
tree
from a set of possible
perturbations
trying to improve the fit now we're
trying to make the sum of squares
on the parse residual as small as
possible
and there's two different ways
perturbation can be made
we can change the structure of the tree
by adding or pruning branches
right we saw that in a picture one case
we added branches in other case we
actually remove the only branch or we
can leave the tree alone
and change the predicted value at each
terminal node
okay so we choose among a set of
perturbations to vary the tree we're
doing here sort of moving around the
tree space right in this kind of in a
similar way bagging and boosting do the
same way they generate a set of trees it
tries to cover the set of possible trees
this is also moving around the tree
space that the space of possible trees
but in a in a different way through
perturbations
here's some examples suppose we start
we're at a step where we have the k
for the k tree we have at step b minus
one this tree
one possibility
for perturbation is to leave the
structure of the tree the same right but
the predictions in the terminal nodes
are are varied a little bit right like
this point four oh seven nines change to
point four four
one etc
another possibility is to remove
a branch well here it actually looks
like we've trimmed off
this
branch here so we've removed these three
terminal nodes right
and then here's another possibility so
instead of trimming a branch we've added
quite a bit of randomness in this in
this trimming rub similar to your mouse
work on the computer
i wish i had a mouse but i don't so okay
so in this fourth example i've added a
branch looks like here right
so it can remove branches add branches
or change the predicted values in the
nodes
so we get from all this we get a
collection of prediction models right at
each step b again our
our prediction is the sum of the
predictions for the k trees
and
as i mentioned the prediction is the
average
of all the predictions at
for all trees and for all b
except that since this is a process
which is random and it starts it starts
in a place and it kind of you hope it's
going to settle down after a while
what's done is a kind of burn in so you
don't actually the first l iterations
you actually throw away
so
maybe b is a thousand l's a hundred that
means you ignore the first 100
steps in the prediction
and you take the average of the
remaining nine hundred so rob what i'm
seeing here is that for any given b
yeah the the bart prediction is like a
boosting model right it's a sum of trees
okay trees
but the difference here is that you got
many of those and and you've created
these many by having this randomization
in the tree selection each time that's
right and another difference is you're
not
building each tree by a simple
tree fit to the residual you're actually
taking the existing tree and doing a
perturbation so it's actually kind of
slower too right you're not fitting as
hard as the data each time
i think we'll see in the example of this
section that the the overfitting is
is reduced by this kind of the slower
learning
another nice thing about bart is not
only do you get as we'll see quite good
predictions you get other quantities
like quantiles right so for example you
can take the percentiles of the
non-burning
predictions as a measure of uncertainty
of the final prediction right you get
not just one number but a collection of
predictions
so if you want say that the 95th
percentile of the prediction you can get
use the the 95th percentile of the
the predictions after burn in here's an
example on the heart data which we've
saw in the book in which we applied
in the first edition we applied it to we
applied bagging and boosting and random
force and now we're going to see what
happens when we apply bart
so the number of trees here was 200
and the number of iterations the b was
up it was brought up to 10 000 right and
the burn in here is 100 you can see
here's the
training and test air for boosting what
you've seen before
that's the dark blue and the dark green
the bart
training error is in gold and the bart
test air is in light blue
and you can see it the training area
goes down more slowly than in boosting
again this is at the evidence that it's
not fitting nearly as hard
but the test error is competitive with
with boosting there it is
so that's that's really interesting
because you can see boosting you know it
really as you as you fit more and more
trees really starts to overfit right the
training error keeps on going down and
the test error starts increasing
but
is showing behavior more like random
forest where
once you reach a certain number of trees
it just flattens off and it's it
it doesn't seem to overfit right it's
not not as aggressive which is one of
the selling points it's it as we say it
it'll work well out of the box you don't
need to tune it very much because it's
not as prone to overfitting as say
boosting is
so where do these perturbations come
from are they just sort of pulled out of
the air well it turns out it's a
bayesian method hence the name bayesian
additive regression trees
and
we didn't talk much in the book about
bayesian methods we talked a little bit
about bayes rule and bayes methods but
the bayesian method starts with a prior
on the parameters
you collect the data you have a sampling
model
you then combine the prior in the
sampling model to get a posterior
distribution
well it turns out that the perturbations
in bart correspond to a certain prior
distribution on the parameters the
parameters here being the the split
points and the values at the terminal
nodes
so we won't go into detail here but it's
a bayesian method under a certain prior
and what we're doing with these
perturbations is actually drawing from
the posterior distribution
from that model
[Music]
furthermore the broad algorithm can be
viewed as a markov chain monte carlo
mcmc method for fitting the bart model
mcmc is a standard way of drawing from a
posterior distribution from a bayesian
model
so the point is that this method which
may seem kind of ad hoc is actually it's
grounded in statistical theory
it's a real posterior distribution from
an actual prior distribution
and we typically choose values for b and
k
that large and the burn ends pretty
moderate
so for example reasonable choices might
be 200 sets of trees
a thousand
iterations or we did 10 000 of that
example and a burning of about 100.
and as i mentioned with selling point of
bart is that it works well
right out of the box without much tuning
which we saw also with random force and
bagging